[Music]
hey everyone I'm ash Carlson and joining
me today an eg favorite David awesome
all Jeff favorite even thank you hi
everybody regular here at this point I
love you and I love being here and
people don't see all the things that I
get to see that are happening around us
yeah secret stuff that we can't even
talk about yeah it's like Marvel level
calling magic yeah it's so good
yep it's so good nothing in here
bringing the the pompadour back a man in
the wasp big time as Kurt such a good
like kind of palette cleanser opposed to
infinity work hasn't paid the best yes I
mean the movies got it's it's a Peyton
Reed movie through and through it's got
like all of his nerdgasm iing it's got
his heart and it's like a film about
family I'm sorry I'll let you keep
talking but I'm really I just saw it for
the first time we're here for you so
proud of it but you really enjoy these
movies as a fan what what did you think
of infinity war first of all backtrack I
love I love the russo so much I loved
infinity war I thought it was so
powerful and it it got that emotional
kick that I got out of the joy when I
first discovered there was a there was a
comic series when I was first really
getting into comics called Secret Wars
in which all the Avengers plus other
members of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
had to come together
I'm not soon it wasn't cinematic then
the Marvel Universe had to come together
to fight this this this entity called
the Beyonder and watching the film
reminded me as they came together to
battle Thanos like that feeling I had
that that that kid in me that got to see
all of your favorite characters coming
together in this battle against this
incredible villain and then like the
impact that it had on me it was a wallop
and and but I did leave it thinking like
man my my son who's just a little too
young for like infinity war like he
he'll see it eventually and he's gonna
love it I know but I was like gosh I
really want him to see a Marvel movie
and then I knew what was coming next
right so I'm really excited that I feel
like this may be the first thing that
I've ever been a part of that I'm gonna
actually why
with my kid right how old is he he's
four he's four okay yeah and one time we
were on a plane and he and I fell asleep
and he manufacturer he figured out how
to to get into the entertainment system
on the TV in hacker he woke me he's just
like they'd make me very proud he woke
me up he's like daddy daddy daddy and I
was like what what what and I looked and
he goes you a bad guy and I looked at
the screen and he had found the flash
and saw an episode where I was
abracadabra and I was like oh well turn
that off because daddy's kind of scary
there but he's seen you on screen then
that counted I guess a little but
framing on the wasp I think it would I
don't know I I haven't talked about with
my wife yet but I think I would love to
take him to like a theatre and see the
movie yeah in this movie he could
totally see let's get into a man in the
wasp yes you just saw for the first time
I did the other night at the premiere it
was very exciting
yeah I'm so thrilled I swear the first
viewing always feels a little weird to
me because it doesn't look real because
I still find it odd that I'm that's like
me up there that's a little surreal but
I also I think about the bag that like
I'm so lucky that that Peyton keeps me
around it doesn't get mad at me or that
Paul and all these other actors because
I just the worst at at breaking and
laughing when they're doing something
and and this scenes going and these
actors start building and improvising
off of the script and they they're
running with it and if there's anybody
that derails that with just
inappropriate laughter have you ever in
ant-man or in a my own the loss could
you ever notice like you're kind of
smirking in the background or something
oh yeah I saw it in the trailer I was
like oh my god I said to Eve I was like
can you tell her and she's like no it
looks like you know character like to me
I can see like the tears welling up in
my eyes and I'm pinching my hand under
the table like don't laugh don't laugh
cuz yes especially if you're with Pena
most of the time cuz he's like you know
just goes he goes and Paul just is is
there the gurus of improv and you know
Paul will start throwing stuff at you
and by the way like there's a scene in
the in the office at ex-con and like
everybody was throwing just ridiculously
hilarious stuff and I was trying not to
laugh
I mean Evangeline Lilly who by the way
we've seen it like she just raises the
bar for the MCU super heroes and
superheroes in general with this movie
like you think we've seen so many
superheroes introduced at this point in
all the movies that we're going to see
who can like take it up a notch yeah she
does man but as much butt kicking and
like awesomeness as she delivers and she
has some really dramatic scenes in it
she's freakin hilarious too man she can
be so funny Michael Douglas was doing
these like dry responses to a bit that I
that you'll see when you see the movie
and that was causing me to laugh they
all can get me you by the way have like
the best reaction to our antagonists of
the movie ghost so good thank you
oh my gosh that cracks me up well Hannah
is amazing in it the characters awesome
it's a new kind of villain that we
haven't seen yet yeah in the MCU her
relationship to Laurence Fishburne who
is so awesome and but I'm gonna movie
with Laurence Fishburne yeah and
Michelle go back to that and many more
times but her relationship with with
fishing and the way that their
characters obsession go that's what he
says that's how he calls himself sorry
Laurence mr. Fishburne no now they are
it's something that we haven't I I loved
watching the way that the film that the
characters journey went because I was
like oh that's really unique and
original and like has a whole new level
of heart to it this movies about keeping
families together about fighting to try
and keep families together and the like
trauma that comes from the families that
have been you know taken apart by
circumstance or by you know in this film
elements that have to deal with science
fiction which are really cool and and
and find their way into the bigger MCU
but but their relationships Laurence
Fishburne and Hanna that you know
between them it's it's beautiful you
know and that's our that's our big
that's our bad person you know if you
will like I still care about her she's
not just
unmotivated villainy you had a very
interesting I was at a lunch with Hamel
gun yes okay because this was like after
nerd news nerd news go back to the nerd
news of what this actually was because
there was tweets back and forth between
Hamill and James Gunn yes
saying hey like we're neighbors and
we've never met and I want to be in
Guardians 3 or whatever let's have lunch
but you were there you know we've been
my family in the panels have been
friends since we worked on sushi girl
together and and mark and I just bonded
over our love of comic books and movies
and stuff well when James and James and
I even had been friends for a number of
years now and he's you know one of my
dearest friends and when he bought his
new house even I were driving up for
like a housewarming and I was like oh my
gosh James's neighbors with mark how
cool is this two of the coolest people I
know are gonna be neighbors now and they
have to meet each other because I just
was like you guys would so hit it off
so anyway Mark's a fan of James James a
fan of Mark they were tweeting at one
another at one point I did send an email
being like just making sure you guys got
each other's info but I think they had
DMD chowder and then we had a we had an
afternoon picnic at the Hamill house and
and James and Jen his amazing girlfriend
came down and Eve my wife and Arlo my
son and Penny my daughter it was
actually the week of her first birthday
so the Hamill's so graciously cuz Nathan
was there marks um son who's a great
artist and his daughter Chelsea them and
Mary Lou they they let us we did a home
we did a birthday cake for penny and and
I I said to Eve it's funny as as
annoying as I'll probably be to my
daughter someday she's gonna think I'm
really cool that she got to have her
first birthday two of the coolest of our
friends so it was awesome to see these
two amazing guys get to know each other
and I was right immediately they just
started going and talking and and it was
really cool to get to be there for that
and I don't know I just think they're
both such wonderful human beings first
yeah and such awesome people and then
when you look at the work that they've
contributed to stuff that I love so much
is just an honor that they're both
friends so you are in the same cinematic
universe as Karen Gillan's but you guys
haven't hadn't worked together gruntal
now correct so you wrote your second
movie yes tell me everything about it
and working with her I had been a fan of
Karen's for so long and obviously she
worked with James and James always spoke
so highly of her and our talented she
was what a cool person she was and all
of our friends
Simon everybody was part of that world
it's been like oh my god karen is the
coolest so I wrote a film called animals
which came out a couple of years ago
directed by my good friend Colin Shipley
which you know had a really wonderful
little life and it continues to grow
now that it's on streaming platforms so
we went to make our second film which is
a script I wrote as well called all
creatures here below which is set back
where I grew up in Kansas
Karen ended up really responding to this
script and I had never met her before
that and I didn't know you know I didn't
know that she would respond as strongly
as she did and she came with just this
incredible vision for this character and
her ideas about the character and we
were so honored that she wanted to be a
part of the film and we were still like
Karen you just come off guardians you
know Jumanji is coming up and you're
you're Karen Gillan you realize like
there's no money we're gonna not have
trailers we're gonna be in hot cars in
the middle of the Kansas summer and she
was like no I have absolutely I want to
do it
so we I'm not doing it again it's lift
out of me that was captured on camera it
was more kirtibhai than Karen's my
Scottish it's not it's not it's not
great my Scottish is it all right there
yeah talking about being on the spot
so she that's Irish yeah so so Karen
came with us to Kansas and we made this
and we had a bunch of other amazing
artists and actors that came aboard that
film and ash like we've all seen her do
so many diverse crazy awesome roles but
I cannot wait for people to see what
Karen Gillan manifested in this I can't
wait we're we're finding out right now
when is it is it gonna be available
we're hopefully I'll come back soon one
more new
on that front soon hey this is you have
a permanent permanent spot on this couch
you guys know that I sleep over there
yeah there's my refrigerator my kids are
over there his little pen hi kids I was
on Getti calm like a photo website and I
was looking for pictures of you and I
saw this picture of you just completely
shirtless yes and I downloaded it and
sent it to you and I was like what's
happening yeah because the people begged
for it I had to do it yeah well the
people the people are always the people
are begging shirtless David um so what
is that what is the story there what
were you doing that there's a picture of
me dancing shirtless with David Wain
were both in ridiculous series of
costumes and that is actually one of the
the most awesome things I've gotten to
be a part of in my in my life
it's a charity event for Children's
Mercy Hospital in Kansas City the event
is called big slick and it's been
happening for I think the last nine
years it's hosted by Paul Rudd Dave
Koechner Eric Stonestreet Rob Riggle and
Jason Sudeikis all of these guys are
natives of Kansas City or the
surrounding area this is the this is a
hospital that just leading the charge in
children's oncology so pediatric cancer
research and treatment they take kids no
matter their financial background you
see kids from all walks of life all
across the Midwest not just around
Kansas City I mean people come from all
over to go to this hospital and it's a
magical very special place that takes
people in it one of the darkest times
that they could experience and I'm just
so lucky that I get to be a part of it
and this year we raised 2.1 million
dollars the biggest ticket item of the
event all the Nerds will freak was when
Paul came out on stage and from the
rafters slowly ascended and a real
Shield of caps I mean a Russell Bobbitt
signature true real prop a Captain
America shield it was vibranium
absolutely I mean this is real and it
had been signed by every one of the
Avengers she's yeah and and a guy I
think they started the bidding like ten
twelve thousand dollars and and
immediately some guy in the back was
like $65,000
and they like oh okay sold that's so
incredible yeah yeah well thank you so
much for coming in by the way thank you
love having you all the time go on yeah
you guys can see Kurt in ant-man and the
wasp oh my gosh yeah here it's here it's
happening it's time
thank you gosh you're the best you're
the best stop it